the Russia ordered humanitarian pause in
the Syrian onslaught against civilians
in one Damascus suburb is being called a
failure by many on the ground tonight
correspondent rich Edson from the State
Department talks to someone responsible
for trying to save as many lives as
possible
this is Syria oh can I Oman PME two
words doomsday right Saleh is the leader
of the white helmets Syrian volunteers
who rushed towards the destruction of
Assad regime barrel bombs and chemical
weapons attacks first responders saving
civilians attacked by their own
government with little equipment aid or
reprieve from years of war now you can
tears have to make crucial decisions
about taking people from rubble no
medical point no hospitals there are no
safe place to transfer those injured a
Russian declared five-hour truce in a
rebel-held area east of Damascus was
supposed to begin today it appears it
did not we'll see these júlio Allah
Russians are considering Syrian
facilities a training field for their
jets they are using and their
destructive power to show civilians
there the United Nations Security
Council also recently passed a 30-day
ceasefire throughout Syria to allow for
aid deliveries and medical evacuations
still the fighting continues Russia
backs the government of Bashar al-assad
providing air cover the United States
holds Russia responsible for what it
calls government chemical attacks on
civilians Moscow plays both arsonist and
fire fighter fueling tensions among all
parties in Syria the Syrian regime Iran
Turkey and Iran - as Fox News has
exclusively learned Iran also an Assad
Ally has built another permanent
military base outside Damascus
complete with hangers that can store
missiles capable of hitting Israel
according to Western intelligence
sources the United Nations investigators
say North Korea has been shipping
supplies to the Syrian government that
it could use to produce chemical weapons
that's according to a UN report the New
York Times review as North Korea becomes
more desperate that they look for
different creative and horrific ways to
try to make money to fund their criminal
regime another obstacle for the few left
to care for a country with little
indication this war
anytime soon sir aha anything about the
what we have witnessed in the last few
weeks the international community is
facing one of helpless in crisis the
United Nations can't do anything in
Syria so lay says he's in Washington to
push the international community to help
stop the fighting especially east of
Damascus where he says food and water
are scarce for the nearly 400,000 living
there Brett Richardson at the State
Department rich thank you